when my wife told me that she was
pregnant I remember thinking wow it
worked that's apparently no one I am one
I want to know more about what it takes
to be a father and celebrate all the
great dads out there oh my god
being the father it's a very fluid thing
it's love at first sight like for real
for real
I'm not Jimmy Fallon anymore I'm
whinnies dad now this dude
lives here forever why my foot I could
fall asleep right now from sleep
deprivation you not to make our family
perfect just make it wonderful you get
the tiniest window and then it's gone
so rebel hard
you're only as happy as your family so
you're very vulnerable
when you're expecting a child they never
prepared for the what-ifs he had two
holes in his heart I'm four l will be
his protector I love you I love my big
spark oh you do
I felt like an imposter but I'm the man
in their life so I have to be excellent
kanmani Nick only question I see I think
I thought too much about one thing that
I learned is that you need to trust your
instincts we know how to do this we went
from no kids to four kids and six months
I literally won the lottery dad I
remember you were worried that you'd
never be as good a dad as your own
father
he was great that's been absolutely my
heart she could be a good dad that is a
blessing that you can pass on is this
normal
No
we had a thousand page manual for a
television and they sent you home with a
baby and nothing it gets really intense
in teenage years your body is changing
oh my god
[Music]
having a kid is the meaning of life this
is my purpose now you are the center of
that child's world your dad what is a
father who knows if I'm the expert this
whole project is in terrible trouble
[Music]
you